so the administration lies about
something they admit it with sake that
they deny it a year and a half later
with Karin Jean-Pierre then Twitter
dumps these docs right so Elon goes to
uh Matt taibi Barry Weiss they unleash
these documents they go around
mainstream media so then mainstream
media ABC NBC CBS does not cover it at
all on their 6 30 PM evening broadcast
which is supposed to be the Nightly News
that would at least one day back in the
day get you caught up on what you needed
to know but now they're by Omission the
default are not allowing you to catch up
on reality and then as we showed you
earlier the New York Times doesn't even
cover it so a certain amount of people
will never be able to see anything true
and then we wonder why so many people
are crazy right because these people
have been gas lit into Oblivion and why
have they because doing the right thing
is a threat is a threat to them if
enough people
had belief in themselves if enough
people could honestly assess what's
going on here and not be forced into
doing things but come to choices by
their own conclusions by their own logic
and reasoning we wouldn't need these
people that much and the whole structure
wouldn't exist that's a problem for them
Jordan Peterson he's got rid of 75 of
the people and Twitter is still
working with record traffic right
exactly and so I think he will and
apparently
he's also
put the boots to the people who are
trafficking and child exploitation
already incredible right no kidding no
kidding in incredible in two ways
incredible that he did it but even more
incredible that he could do it that fast
and that it hadn't been done
isn't that the point nobody cared about
the freaking child porn issue on Twitter
until three weeks ago and suddenly
there's too much child porn on Twitter
because Elon has it and he's actually
doing something about it
things are changing right in front of
our face there is a chance that that
superstructure that exists that has
confused so many people that more and
more people can get out of it